[Applause]
[Music]
okay welcome nice to meet you too one of
the most annoying topics of development
security okay my name is Nico Coppola I
am from Germany I'm a frilly ins guy and
I'm more than 20 years in IT business
I recognize that a few weeks ago when I
got my new fitness trackers has a very
small display and I have to put my wrist
far away from my eyes so I'm getting
pretty old
besides my day job I co organizing local
Java user group and um start it's never
Frankfort and speak occasionally at tech
conferences all over the world and last
year I wrote a book about service
computing in the cloud but that's not
the topic how we talk about today and of
course as every speaker and developer
whatever I I'm on Twitter so let's start
talking about security who a few likes
to deal with security one two three four
three and a half okay fill in a half
it's not that pretty much so did I until
a few years ago the reason was for me I
didn't understand it then I checked the
time and try to understand it read the
specs and suddenly it made hey it's easy
it's pretty easy but you have to have to
take the time and understand how all
this stuff really works and security is
a wide range of topics and they're also
the OVAs top ten which deal with the
most most frequent security issues and
but we don't want to talk about the top
ten today we want to talk about often
occasion and authorization so who a few
things he or she knows what's a
difference because between authorization
and authentication okay bit more than Li
half it's pretty easy I think but every
time I'm talking to customers most of
them don't get it right and it's easy as
authentication is I don't know who you
are please authenticate yourself tell me
who you are and how can I make sure that
you the person you tell me you are an
authorization is the next step after I
know who you are
I have to check what are you allowed to
do this is authorization and yeah also I
mix it up still in my daily person is
business when talking to customers
sometimes I say authentication when I
mean authorization and vice versa so if
I mix it up today please don't be angry
with me but also the HTTP status codes
mix it up a bit and yes these are pretty
old so the guys who made who who built
up the status codes didn't get it either
we have the four one which means which
which is called unauthorized but it
means unauthenticated or not
authenticated for one is not really it
does not deal with authorization it
deals with authentication and once you
are authenticated because status code
four or three tells you you don't you
are you're not allowed to do anything
you're forbidden so for one unauthorized
it's not it's not really correct so and
we are in distributed api's nowadays the
tributed systems the cpu today's api's
at least we have single page application
in the backend that's also a distributed
system and how do we log in in such a
system in a secure way and when talking
when api's are talking to each other we
how do they authenticate and authorize
each other and when it comes oh yeah
when we have distributed the api's or
distribution systems should we have a
centralized approach when it comes to
authorization or authentication I think
yes because it's called a single sign-on
and single sign-on means there's only
one system who knows my credentials and
which knows how to verify these
credentials and not two or three or more
replicated systems with replicated data
because then the the data the credential
data of our users is replicated and many
systems have haven't have a knowledge
about this and we don't want to have
many systems or most more than one
system to have the knowledge how to
verify the credentials only one system
that's because it's it's called single
sign-on single sign-on does not mean our
users only have to login once when they
come into the office in the morning and
grab a coffee and they can work with FF
system that's a side effect of single
sign-on but not that's not the root of
the word single sign-on the single is
really the single system who knows about
our credentials yeah and when it comes
to to real users of course they want to
have a simple and secure solution and
you all know simply simple and secure
these are two choose one
you always have to choose what is more
relevant for you has it to be more
simple or has it beat or more secure the
more secure the less simple it will be
at least for you as a developer if you
want to make it simple for therefore the
users for the end users and secure for
the data then the effort is at your side
the developers site yeah how do you
often ticket of course with our username
email wherever a password a simple
secret or temporary link or a mobile
phone or whatever but then how do we
transport these authentication infos to
all the systems of course with the token
and the token is nothing new already in
the beginning of 2000's we have the the
sam'l security assertion markup language
which is pretty cool XML new XML and
cool doesn't work doesn't fit together
it's yeah it's powerful but it's kind of
complex and it doesn't feel good and all
these claims are difficult to handle and
when we talk today about web
applications and lightweight lightweight
serialization and such things like Jason
JavaScript it's really hard to handle
XML with JavaScript I tried it once and
I gave up after 2 days but the token
itself is nothing really new and because
sam'l isn't working pretty good with web
technologies in nowadays
there's the Hoth - framework or
specification which deals with
authorization or of - has nothing to do
with authentication it just deals with
authorization who is allowed to do what
which system may access another system
in your name of course you have to be
authenticated before you can give
another third party system the authority
to access your own system but the
authentication process is no standard
way when using OAuth 2 or 2 is just
authorization and the authentication
process is completely different
implemented when looking at the U of
implementation of Twitter or Facebook or
of github or whatever so you can use the
login feature of Twitter or Facebook
Google for your application but that's
not really authentication that's only
authorization you grant access to your
application to access Twitter in your
name when you're not in front of your
computer and furthermore if you
implement many of these providers you
have to implement different ways of how
to retrieve the user information the
user profile information because every
response from effort system looks
different so although of to is just for
authorization and not for authentication
but is pretty powerful when it comes to
web web applications or handling in the
web and it has different so-called
Krantz types or authorization flows
they're the authorization code
the standard flow which deals with many
redirects between the systems and the
browser and simple said the the user
wants to access okay I can show you here
an abstract protocol flow the user wants
to access a secured resource on the
resource server and the resource server
says hey you're not authenticated please
login or educate yourself and then I
will see if you're allowed to do and
redirects the user to login page of the
authorization server and after the user
locks in the authorization server sends
back a an authorization code that's why
it's called the authorization code flow
and the authorization with the
authorization code flow in the browser
with a redirect to the application the
client wants to access the application
itself can crap the token from the
authorization server and the token
expresses what the user is allowed to do
so with the token the resource server
can deliver the protected resource to
the client that's the most powerful
ground-type or authorization flow
authorization code and if you don't have
the the ability to to take the
authorization code flow and grab the
token from the authorization server
because that's you need you need an
additional secret for the for the client
fetching the the token at the
authorization server and if you can't
provide this secret for example in a
public web site JavaScript side
you need something other because yeah
you can somehow encrypt or hash the
secret but it's still in the in the
front and the browser and the users
device so the secret isn't a secret
anymore and therefore you have the
implicit flow and with the implicit flow
you get implicit the token back to the
response after the user locks in
successfully if you don't have any
chances or you don't want to have some
redirects between systems and the users
browser you can use the resource owner
password credentials flow it sprite
quite a nice resource only password
credentials I have to read it every time
and that's kind of an API sending the
credentials directly to the
authorization server and get back the
token but this is the least least secure
possibility because you as as the client
application have you have to have the
credentials in in your application to
send it to the authorization server in
the regular cases of authorization code
or implicit flow the author's
authorization server delivers the login
page and the user enters his credentials
directly at the other authorization
server and with a resource on a path of
potentials flow the user enters the
credentials at your application and you
take the application other credentials
and send them to the authorization
server so there are chances for men the
middle attacks and when it comes to
system system authorization there's the
client credentials flow this is just for
like it's like the idea of a relation
code
or the implicit flow but just for
back-end applications
there's no prouder involved and no
redirects and lastly you have the
Refresh token flow because every token
has a special lifetime and after the
token is invalid you have to renew
refresh the jokin we can do this with
the Refresh token flow and that's how
the access token response looks like
when your application gets the response
from the token fetch or formulas
reauthorization server you have the
access token itself it can be Chester o
pack string with no means for outside
world the token type is Bearer it's
always better when dealing with off -
this is written in the spec as the s and
expiry range it expires in 3600 seconds
and we have the Refresh token with the
Refresh token you can refresh in village
access token so normally the access
token has a very short lifetime between
a few seconds and I say five minutes and
the Refresh token has a long lifetime
let's say half an hour an hour or
whatever so this access token you can
take this access token the string and to
know what your user or your client is
allowed to do you have to take this
access token and ask the authorization
server
what is this user with this access token
allowed to do and additionally you don't
know who is this user
you can only check what is this user
allowed to do you don't know who is this
user and this is where open ID connect
games in open ID Connect is not open ID
yet nothing has nothing to do with open
ID
it's just hosted by the Open ID
Foundation which is also doing open ID
and but it's called open that you
connect and it's based technically it's
based on all of - with the OAuth 2 flows
and it standardizes profile user profile
information and identity information so
it brings in an identity token to the
additionally to the access token we have
an identity token and it adds user
profile endpoint where you can grab
identity information profile information
of the user with his current access
token and a few more restful endpoints
for dealing with all this stuff so this
is the identity token coming in into the
response we have the access token the
Refresh token know we have identity
token but how does it look like how is
the identity start into the token and
this is where JSON web tokens come in
JSON web token it's a standard since
2015 three years old and JSON web tokens
are simply three concatenated base64
encoded strings so if the three strings
mentioned in different colors and what
it is like is that the header is payload
and it's a signature and if you decode
this can you read it here I think yes
you see the header it just contains the
type the jpg has the JWT has the type
JWT okay
and the algorithm with which the
signature is signed or the signature is
created then you have the payload for
the payload you have a few reserved
claims we can assume in the next slide
the possible claims all the attributes
are called claims in terms of JWT and
the signature if it's a string
concatenated of base64 encoded header
and payload and depending on the the
type of the algorithm used a
synchronized algorithm the HS 256 with
just a secret or you can use the hours
to five six for a private public key
usage so the token itself is so-called
self-contained
and you can always check if the token
was changed by some third party when you
get the token and so you have a certain
kind of trust level when you get the
token if the token itself is valid or
it's not valid because only if you knew
you even know the the secret when it
comes to synchronized signature or you
have to know the private key when
dealing with public private public key
encryption so you don't have to check
the token at a another endpoint you can
this can do this of course if you really
need this kind of security but you don't
have to use this endpoint yeah the
payload itself it sets some reserved
claims the subject issuer audition and
expiry
these are the only claims JWT claims for
itself the subject is for for whom is
the the token issued most of the time
this is kind of a user ID the issuer is
the issuing system represented as in URL
the audition for which client
application this token was issued for my
API or for my shop or for whatever
system and the expiry date and a suspect
says jwg mustn't be used when the expiry
date has expired so you have to check
the signature of the signatures valid
then you can use the token otherwise you
must not use the soakin and it has to
have a valid expiry date the rest of the
payload you can choose freely whatever
you want to put in the payload as you
like
almighty connect adds a more some more
claim standard claims to the JWT token
so if you use JWT in terms of all my ID
connect you have to use these claims and
I don't know it's difficult to read
there was no other way to fit all the
information to you to one slide it's but
it's on a website of my D so we have
claims for the name the given name the
family knee and the middle name the
nickname preferred username and so on
also in the bottom you can see there's
also address and address is not only
string it's a JSON object so we have a
nested object for the address
information and the FS object itself is
also specified so
using JWT changes our access token
response to look like this we have the
access token the access token itself is
when using almighty connect also
expressed in JWT and if the token type
the expires in when using JWT you don't
need to use this expires in a tripod
because the token itself has an expiry
date and you have the identity token in
a JWT format and the Refresh token also
it doesn't make real sense to have the
Refresh token as a JWT but yeah for
simplicity reasons all tokens are JWT
tokens the reach token itself contains
just unique string for identifying this
session on the authorization server okay
and how can this tile can be used the
user after of the successful
authentication has a token he passes to
the web application and the web
application itself can pass the same
token to back-end systems if this
application needs to access third party
or further back-end systems as we can
see later in the demo it's also possible
that the web application grabs an own
so-called service account token for
authentication authenticate
authenticating itself against back-end
systems or it can pass the the user
token to the back-end systems so short
conclusion for tokens a token assigned
we have seen this and contains all
necessary information about a user and
its roles so in the access token
all the roles the user has should be
included we have different kinds of
tokens with identity tokens refresh
tokens access tokens and sometimes you
have things like like an offline token
and often in token you can a user can
can request to have an offline token
issued for another application and this
and this other application can use this
offline token for perhaps regular tasks
at night when the user is not online
creating reports or whatever sending
emails to to exchange this offline token
to well it access token and act in
behalf of the user even if the user is
not online but the user has to has to
initiate the process for for creating an
offline token so there's no global
offline token as a system can use to act
in behalf of a user the tokens are sent
in bearer form are most often in the
HTTP header authorization and we have a
total time to live and of course tokens
must be revocable I forgot this to
mention an access token itself
once it is issued it doesn't need to be
verified at the authorization server I
said before that's right because it's
signed and it's self-contained so once
it is issued it is well it and every
system using it can be can be sure that
it's valid but but what if the the token
is stolen or whatever that's because the
the access token should have a very very
short
total time to live I recommend most
often between 30 seconds and 2 minutes
because that's the time amount of time a
third party can misuse this token if it
gets the token and after this time you
have to use the Refresh token and to
refresh the excess toner get a new
access token and if you have in the mean
time the token the session revoked at
the authorization server the server
won't access in you exit wound oh no
won't one create a new access token and
and the third party can't use their
token anymore so this must be revocable
and as I'm a Chaba developer most of the
times currently I'm dealing with the
JavaScript I ask myself what does Chava
offer to deal with oauth2 and Almighty
connect and unfortunately it's not that
much it's becoming better but it's very
said the big Java EE standard now it's
called Jakarta ee has a new security api
jsrf tooth seven five which is quite
nice this api but it doesn't deal with
of - or almighty connect JWT there are
some discussions on the mailing list and
the issue list to integrate it or not
and how to do it but for now there's
nothing included and string security
already made off to a first-class
citizen in its implementation and
before security 5 you had to use a
third-party library to use OAuth 2 and
open ID connect with spring security now
it's included out of the box in spring
security and there's some other
libraries for example there's a patchy
Shiro one of the well-known libraries
dealing with security but also try ro
doesn't have off to automatically
connect JWT included there's some
community efforts but nothing in the
library itself but there's another
library called Apache all to which does
contain all the standards and my
favorite questionnaire every conference
who knows all to one ok yeah even me
didn't know this library until I
prepared the talk and how to look which
libraries are out there dealing with
both - and yeah it seems it's it's it's
powerful library but nobody knows there
are lots of more libraries available
some dealing with orth - automatic
connect some not and there of course a
lot of libraries dealing with JWT
looking at the ecosystem what's
available for storing user data and
providing all the flows and processes
and points of course you can use of zero
or HW s cognitive storm half some
managed services providing all this
functionality but you have to outsource
you use this data of the current Angeles
and that's I think most of the time not
that's what you want to do to give other
companies the credentials of
users and besides other projects I liked
you to use key clock from tables it's an
open-source project it's not just a
library it's a complete system providing
all the services for Identity and Access
Management and yeah in most of the cases
it can be a good fit I also had some
case the use cases at customers where I
said ok key clock can do it but it's not
the best fit for you needs
take another solution but in the last
few years most of the projects I did
with my customers I introduced key clock
to them and they're pretty happy so
let's look into some demo how I did it
first the architecture it's pretty
simple I have a shop system as the the
main system a user interacts with and
stock service and the shipping service
in the backend and the user gets user
token passage to the shop and the shop
itself gets an service account token
issued for accessing the stock service
because the stock service is also
secured only allowed resources may
access the the stock service and for
calculating the shipping costs the the
shipping service needs the user token so
the shop pass the user token to the
shipping service so this is key clock
this is the year the admin interface and
I have to
I have created a shop client this is my
shop application and the client protocol
is open I do connect key talk also
support summer but we don't want to deal
with some over until only to deal with
automatic connect and this is a
confidential client which means this
client has a secret for accessing the
key clock server like a password for for
the for the system itself and you can
find it here it's the secrets generated
and yeah we have a user user has user
name user and this user has a roller
called user very surprising and yeah we
can now access our shop oh I have to
start it first it's spring a spring boot
application I will show you some some
code a few minutes so we have the shop
localhost
no it's better it's my shop and come
from Germany that's because the Euro
symbol and I want to access a secured
secured resource and the application
redirects me to the key clock server to
log in and all the things you can see on
this page are coming with kiki look you
don't have to implement them themselves
the login process you have a register
option you have forgotten password
option you have Remember Me option you
have the option to to use social login
providers or you
can come connect your your your LDAP or
Active Directory to key cloak so that
key cloak just does the authentication
process but the credentials are stored
in Active Directory and all this stuff
you don't have to implement it yourself
and then we can log in as a user and
that's my cat shop you can buy cats you
can see I'm the user and now I can put
cats into the cart some double rounding
feature we can see we have some stock
information about the cats and the image
service-based slow it's a public service
with random pics and we have shipping
costs of approximately a 10 euro and if
I now look out and do some
reconfiguration of my user ID ciao
it's a wee up here I give the user just
a simple attribute with a value true and
now if login again and put cats into my
cart you can see there are no shipping
costs because if the user has we appear
attribute there are no shipping costs
used so that's the application itself
let's look into the code how what I had
to do to realize all this besides of the
of the business logic for configuration
of key clock for springboard application
and
spring Buddhism it's really simple but
other java application service are quite
similar we have to provide some
configuration it's a realm it's called
what Suresh make let's look
yeah it's called walk sewage this is the
real configure in key clock
we have server URL it's localhost 8080
we have the the secret our resource is
called shop we we saw this and in our
principle attribute we want to have the
preferred username claim that's one of
the autumn ID Connect reserved claims
and we use the servlet security
specification to configure security
collection which says all resources
beneath the path shop should require a
user role that's why we were redirected
to the login page
I didn't write a read wrote any code to
redirect the user to the login page just
this configuration leads to the login
page of key club because the key clock
adapter which is included in the
application which is just a dependency
in the palm have you keep log
springboard starter and this dependency
brings all the adapter logic to redirect
to this server and if I authenticate
myself come back to the application and
the application fetches the access token
from the key log server and knows I'm a
valid user with a user role and leads me
to the catalog which is
done by the shop controller and when we
have looked to the stocks get stocks
method we have the sucks service get
stocks and we use a rest template which
I called key clock kind of rest template
and I implemented myself it's just an
extended standard rest template from
spring and did some configuration magic
there's the arrest template and make use
of the earth client offset client this
client comes where comes with key log
adapters the dependency mentioned in the
pom.xml and this client eases the
process for authentication of educating
the the the application itself against
key clock to get a service account
access token which is needed by the
stock service and we can see the stock
service the service itself needs the
role stocks and as we can see it our
user our user doesn't have the role
stocks it's available but it's not
assigned and our client shop there was a
controls there it is has an assigned
role stocks so the shop application
itself verifies authenticates itself and
key clock gets an access token and
passes it to the start service and
because the the token contains the
stocks role it's allowed to access the
stock service
and we have the the shipping service at
at last service this also needs the
users role and key clock for votes the
talk the user token to the the shipping
service and in the shipping controller I
can get I can access the key clock
security context through the the request
and in this context I can get a token or
also I can get some identity token to
get identity information or whatever I
need and here I checked the the VIP
claim just for completeness and the
interesting part is and the shop
application again shipping service I
just use a regular rest template but I
configured the rest template to use the
key clock rest template customizer this
also comes with key lock and the key
clock rest template customizer is so I
need to find it no that's just an
interface the Interceptor yes the
Interceptor and the Interceptor just
cares about getting attributes from the
request get the user principle and
somewhere you know getting the key clock
security context and putting the the
token the token from the security
context into the request to the shipping
service to the backend so I didn't write
any code to secure my applications just
did configuration using the key clock
application
the key clock system server and can can
make use of a highly secured application
landscape so that's it
time is over I hope you enjoyed the
session and if you have any questions we
have some four minutes left
just ask your questions raise your hands
or come in front of me yeah
the code is not yet online but I can put
it online later on and I will tweet the
pass through repository so just follow
me at does nico and it will be informed
okay because but it's no real code it's
just configuration the code is standard
java spring boot code it's nothing
there's no security code it's just
configuration make use of the the key
clock some key clock magic about the
configuration of the rest templates but
nothing more yeah okay that's one more
did everybody understand the question or
should I repeat it okay
what's the what's the purpose of
securing the boss back back-end systems
the stock service and the shipping
service because normally we should be in
a controlled and secured area if it's
really secured in this area most of the
the attacks in systems came from
internal net internal networks and even
if you're in your own intranet
controlled whatever at least the the
administrator knows how to attack a
system and you should secure all your
systems regardless if the if their
environment claims to be secure or not
you should always use HTTPS you should
always use authentication and
authorization so we always can can check
at the stock service when and how often
the shop accessed the stock service so
for auditing reasons or whatever you can
you have the best basics
in the second you propagate the user
identity to the shipping service yes but
this can be can be needed because
somewhere piece don't have to pay
shipping costs whatever yeah but this
always also can be it can be a risk of
propagating user identities to other
systems so we have always deal with the
pros and cons of your solution no system
is perfectly secure he asked if I missed
why I missed the the Scopes from off to
and if it's a missing feature of key
clock why I'm using roles and not scopes
which which scopes exactly do you mean
from fourth to
okay okay it's just really a part of the
specification or is this way of most
companies do it okay
key yeah
Kiki clock first of all makes use of all
mighty connect and JWT and mighty
connect is based on all of - just for
the the flows and because of mighty
connect uses JWT and JWT can express all
what you want you don't have to use some
other possibilities scopes into
additionally the two - JWT so we can put
all the information you need in your
token you don't have to use scopes from
one technology from the earth to
technology and use tokens from from
almighty connect of course you can mix
it if you want you can how are you you
you put your your your authorization
information into the token if it's roles
or scopes it's completely up to you but
Almighty connect is not with
authorization it deals with
authentication and in authentication you
don't need roles or scopes it's just in
addition to all this kind of stuff and
yeah authorization with key clock can be
a pain in my eyes for authentication
it's pretty good
authenticate an authorization can be
really pain okay times over thank you
all for listening
and have a nice day
[Applause]